welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Voss and Loki season 2 just changed a
script of reality in the MCU yet again
with a season premiere that hops around
in time inside of the walls of the time
variant Authority a place that we
previously understood to be the one
neutral zone to any of this timeline Tom
fullery the episode calls this time
slipping a kind of glitch in he remains
Matrix and it's one of the many new
terms in the MCU glossery that many of
us had to rewatch scenes a few times to
fully grasp along with temporal Aura
temporal Loom spaghettification and book
as know what that is is that like an
emotion or a type of food well back in
season 1 and in the years in between I
put a lot of time into chronicling the
chronology of the Sacred timeline and
the branch timelines outside of the TVA
but now we're learning there's a
separate history of causal events inside
of the TVA and in this video I am going
to break down the timeline of the time
variance Authority when everything in
this episode happens the different eras
of the TVA that this first episode of
season 2 takes place in and really the
new things we just learned about the
tva's history like how it's even more
based on The Matrix simulation cycle
than we realized with an architect and
past versions erased from memory by the
way be sure to check out our Easter egg
breakdown of the premiere episode plus
our inside Marvel reaction over the
break room Channel where we break down
some theories for the ending of the
episode and then tomorrow here on the
main new rockstars Channel Jessica
Clemens and I are back teaming up for a
weekly sneak peek series coming out on
Sundays where we are going to look ahead
to the next episodes of Loki okay while
watching season 2 episode 1 of Loki in
the new rockstars office on Thursday
night I realized I didn't really
understand the timeline of everything as
as well as I thought I did the Mobius in
the B15 that Loki ran up to in the
archives in the final scene of season 1
who were fretting about like 63 new
branches that needed to be pruned those
were not the same mobs and B15 who a
couple scenes earlier had been staring
up at the Timeline screen in the Chron
monitor Bay these two in the archives
were from an earlier era of the TVA than
the other two were now the whole idea of
the TVA having multiple historical eras
that feed into each other seems to
change the logic of what we previously
knew to be true like last season in the
very first episode of L Oki series
Mobius explained how long have you been
here I don't know it's hard to say you
know time passes differently here in the
TVA what does that mean and then now in
the season 2 premiere Mobius is
rightfully confused I mean did you come
straight from the end of time no I was
in the past what do you mean in the past
where in the past here here the past TVA
no there is no past TVA time doesn't
work but it does not because it's
happening to me it's impossible it's
possible
m so when I was in the office that night
I realized I needed to try to chart this
out to understand it and then like I was
in a trance I just wandered to the
nearest whiteboard and I kind of blacked
out for a half hour and here is what I
came up with and then our postproduction
team came up with a much cleaner version
so that you don't have to discern any of
my handwriting okay so let's break down
what this is this episode takes place
across four or five eras within the
boundaries of the TVA and I say within
the boundaries of the TVA because I'm
not counting any of the outside world of
the Sacred timeline or any of the branch
timelines that is part of the historical
backdrop that they are like rewriting
and revising and tinkering with and that
includes the Sylvie post credit scene in
broon Oklahoma no I'm just talking about
what takes place within this workplace
and the things connected to it so this
episode actually begins in the past TVA
before the timekeepers that's where Loki
ended season one when Heath fre remains
was in the statues all over the TVA so
Loki flees a Mobius and a B15 who hadn't
met him yet he meets a Casey who doesn't
know him he sees statues of the Kang
variant he remains out in the open this
is before he remains switched to
pretending the timekeepers were running
the show then Loki Time Slips back and
forth between this era and the present
TVA which is where the main events of
this episode take place now we should be
clear Loki Time Slips at like two or
three other times this episode but
rather than following him when he Time
Slips we actually stay with Mobius in
these instances so we don't really know
where he went but I'm going to assume it
was the past TVA for reasons I'll get to
later Loki also Time Slips to this past
TVA to get to the Past war room where
instead of timekeepers like five faces
of he who remains are on the wall and he
hears a recording of he who remains in
Ren Slayer indicating that at one point
in the future or in the past they ran
the TVA together now the present TVA is
of course where all the TVA scenes in
Loki season 1 took place and in season 1
we last saw it with that shot of movus
and B15 in the Chron monitor Bay looking
up at the screen so Loki Time Slips to
this present and we spend most of the
season 2 premiere right here Loki
crashes the War Room meeting he prunes
back that timekeeper mural to prove that
underneath it was he remains face and
those faces were just left there under
the wallpaper rather than just wholly
reconstructed by he remains which tells
you something about this guy's ego like
he expected to loop back to this someday
like the timekeepers were always
temporary to him also in the president
TVA Loki and Mobius go to the RNA
Department to meet President Day OB and
then Loki Time Slips again to an even
earlier era of the TVA presumably at
least 400 years prior according to OB
who said that Mobi is visiting him
around 400 years prior was previously
his most recent visitor though by time
slipping to whatever that past was Loki
is technically altering obes history so
that doesn't necessarily mean he time
slipt all the way back 400 years it
could have been sometime in between but
whenever this previous error was it's
one where Obi does not have glasses and
the RNA department has a Sprite machine
that looks really old and way fewer work
tickets so I'm assuming it's
significantly before the past TBA
pre-time keeper era that I talked about
so in this further past Loki plants new
memories in Obie's mind and then tells
him to construct a temporal oral
extractor to store it for his future
self which he finds immediately back in
the present TVA as time has been warped
to make this so now long time new
rockstars viewers know how much we use G
geology and how long we've been using it
for but if this is your first time
hearing about geology get ready for
Blockbuster quality skincare on a
student film budget geology is a 23 time
award-winning skin hair and body care
company recognized in men's health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and GQ
geology's products are just a handful of
powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades geology can help you fight acne
reduce oiless prevent wrinkles combat
dark or puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
everything you need to keep your skin
healthy no matter how much you soak in
the pool this summer don't know where to
start geology can create a simple and
effective skin care or hair care routine
for you all you got to do is take a
quick 30second quiz right now if you use
the code new rockstars 100 geology will
give you 100% off their award-winning
skincare trial set you'll also get an
additional bonus offer of up to 30% off
one skin hair or body products when you
add it to your trial it's truly a wild
offer one the best they've ever given
our audience so click the link in the
description or go to geol log. i/
rockstars 100 to get started they use
this device to Stage an extraction for
Loki's temporal Aura from this chaotic
time stream outside of the temporal Loom
but then Loki Time Slips again this time
to a near future era and rather than it
being any distant future it seems to
just be either a few hours or a few days
Beyond where we just were in the present
M's tracing of the word skin is still in
the dust there so it hasn't been that
much time for like dust to recover it
the blast doors to the temporal Loom are
closed but it hasn't yet fully consumed
the TVA and destruction so in this near
future Loki looks for a Time stick sees
Sylvie gets pruned by someone and then
comes out of the time stream back in the
TVA present so that covers four eras of
the TVA in this episode the fifth era
that I referred to I think it gets
hinted at in this episode a time period
within the TVA a distant future at the
end of time this I believe is when Ren
Slayer and he remains conversation was
recorded let's take a listen to that you
are quite a
mod I will be proud to lead with
you you made a difference in this war
thank you for being on my team so I
think this conversation is actually
happening in the Citadel at the end of
time because that's where he remains
always is and remember that Citadel is
also detached from the sacred timeline
or any of its branches and it just seems
to be on its own AIS like the TVA is
it's not connected to like the history
we live in it's kind of in its own space
So based on their conversation this is
happening at the end of the multiversal
war that has been referenced before but
you may ask wait if that multiversal war
ended long ago according to miss minutes
animation video wouldn't a conversation
at the end of this war using the word
this war also must have taken place long
ago long ago there was a vast
multiversal War now you could say Miss
minut might have been lying about when
exactly it was I mean there's a lot of
lies in that video but he remain told
Loki and Sylvia that there was a past
multiversal War so I believe that much
but here's where I'm going to confuse
you further about where exactly the
Citadel at the end of time is or when it
is Stay With Me the Citadel at the end
of time is also at the beginning of time
the Citadel at the End of Time must be
at the end of time because that is what
it's called but I believe it is also the
origin point of all time it's where it
all began this is the rock upon he who
remains built his church and constructed
the TVA spawning its own inner history m
wasn't wrong time does pass differently
in the TVA and I believe it's because
time in the TVA is a flat circle it's on
a loop it's a cycle of hard work toiling
pruning adjusting the flow of time of
the outside world trying to build a
perfect utopian sacred timeline and then
inevitable failure self-destruction
implosion and then reset the cycle
repeats so I posed a question why is it
that both the present TVA and the past
TVA are both going through different
crises of Branch timeline overloads the
we see in the temporal Loom of the
present TVA and that past one that B15
and Mobius were in The Archives
spreading about the 63 branches whatever
that was I think it's because in every
era of the TVA things always reach a
point of Crisis the bubble always bursts
the dam always breaks Revolution always
happens and everything is always reset
it's kind of like what Ragnarok actually
is in North mythology he remains was
introduced to us like kind of an
architect in The Matrix and remember
when Neo and Matrix Reloaded met the
architect the architect explained that
Neo wasn't the first anomaly to reach
him that this was all actually the sixth
iteration of the Matrix and that there
is always an anomaly who breaks
everything and in the Loki series that
anomaly was Sylvie or at least Loki and
Sylvie joining forces and together
breaking the system because I believe it
was Matrix directions that implied that
both Neo and Trinity needed each other I
don't know if you don't want to consider
matorx Resurrection Canon I don't blame
you so after all these past eras of the
tvi get destroyed he remains always
resets it and in one of those resets he
wiped everyone's memory so that the
timekeepers would be perceived as the
bosses is not him thinking maybe that's
why that particular past era failed he
also wipes their memories of certain
other aspects of the TVA as Mobius did
not remember OB but maybe he remains
needs one employee to retain his
memories reset after reset so that the
author of The TVA guide book will be a
legacy custodian to keep everything
running so the way Sylvie hopped from
apocalypse to apocalypse Loki is time
slipping among TVA ragnaroks and once he
figures out the secret of why
continually ragnaroks every few hundred
years he's going to realize that he
remains function is both necessary and
doomed to fail a truth hidden in plain
sight of this broken timeline just as my
own ghostly reflection was hidden in
that whiteboard photo subscribe to all
three channels in the new rockstars
Network you can follow me on all social
platforms at eaos thanks for watching
I'll see you next time bye
y'all